welcome to chess comm chess comm is
social now you can play chess with your
friends whenever you want
whether that's middle of the day or
middle of the night you can get
instantly matched up with one of over
five million other members from around
the world you play live games in real
time turn-based games at your
convenience or tournaments with anyone
at any time
chess comm is mobile you can play online
from your computer or you can play on
the go from your tablet or your
smartphone no matter where you go
whether you're at work grabbing a bite
to eat or just enjoying some time in the
park your games are there with you and
keeping multiple chess games going has
never been easier chess comm is for
learning don't just play chess get
better the best chess training resources
have never been more accessible learning
central chess strategy quickly and
easily with the extremely popular
tactics trainer tool improve your game
in ways you didn't were possible with
training videos by chess masters and
regardless of where you're at now take
your game to the next level with
multiple simple to use training tools
chess comm is for everyone over 250
million chess games have been played on
chess calm
and it doesn't matter if you're beginner
or Grandmaster chess comm is the place
to play and learn chess so create your
free account now see what chess comm is
for you